WITH THE FIRING OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEW,
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWT
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWI
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWS
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWA
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWL
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWT
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWO
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND IN MY VIEWN
IMPROPER ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE
PRESIDENT NOW HAS THIS
INVESTIGATION IN HIS SIGHTS.
>> Laura: OUTGOING
SENATOR JEFF FLAKE HAS PERFECTLY
SUMMED UP HIS CAREER IN THE
UPPER CHAMBER.
DESPITE ZERO EVIDENCE OF ANY
THREAT TO THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, FLAKE IS NOW
SAYING HE LOST THE CONFIRMATION
OF HIGHLY QUALIFIED CONSERVATIVE
JUDGES ACROSS THE LAND.
HERE NOW TO REACT IS FORMER
WHITEWATER INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
KENNETH STARR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ANDY McCARTHY.
ANDY, DO YOU THINK THIS BILL
THAT FLAKE AND IS NEWFOUND
DEMOCRATIC BUDDIES IS OFFERING
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL?
EXPLAIN.
>> WELL, ALL OF THE AUTHORITY IN
THE CONSTITUTION IN ARTICLE TWO,
ALL THE EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY IS
VESTED IN THE PRESIDENT.
IN OUR SYSTEM, PROSECUTION IS AN
EXECUTIVE POWER.
YOU CANNOT PASS A CONSTITUTIONAL
BILL THAT ESSENTIALLY TAKES AWAY
THE PRESIDENT'S EXECUTIVE POWER
AND THE PRESIDENT'S POWER TO
LEAD THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
PROPOSES IT TO SOMEONE ELSE
WHETHER IT'S THE PROSECUTOR
HIMSELF OR ANOTHER BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT TO OVERSEE HIM.
THE REASON PEOPLE OPPOSE THIS,
LAURA, AS A LEGAL MATTER IS THAT
IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BUT AS A FACTUAL MATTER, AS YOU
SUGGEST, THIS IS PURE
GRANDSTANDING AND THEATRICS
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES THERE IS NO
REASON TO BELIEVE THERE IS A
THREAT TO THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THINK ABOUT ANY OF
THE PHENOMENAL YOUNG LAWYERS WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR
CONFIRMATION.
APPELLATE COURTS JUDGES,
DISTRICT COURT JUDGES, MILITARY
COURT.
YOU JUST WANT TO HOLD THEM OFF?
>> IT'S TERRIBLE.
IT REALLY IS.
I AGREE FULLY WITH ANDY.
THERE IS NO FORESEEABLE THREAT.
THERE JUST ISN'T.
I UNDERSTAND THAT -- WAIT, WHO
IS THIS MR. WHITAKER GUY AND
WHAT DID HE SAY AS A CNN
COMMENTATOR, BUT HE'S NOW AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
ITS REGULAR ORDER.
AS YOU WELL KNOW, LARA, THEIR
PROCESSES WITHIN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SO HE'LL BE
CONSULTING ON THESE KINDS OF
ACTIONS THAT CAN AFFECT THE
INVESTIGATION.
HE'S NOT A SOLO PERFORMER.
>> Laura: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
WHITAKER APPOINTMENT, AND YOU
HAVE KELLYANNE CONWAY'S HAS BEEN
SAYING THIS IS COMPLETELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO NOMINATE
AS ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
BECAUSE HE HAS NOT BEEN
NOMINATED BY THE SENATE.
>> WHITAKER IS EFFECTIVELY A
CONSTITUTIONAL NOBODY.
>> I THINK MATTHEW WHITAKER'S
APPOINTMENT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
ILLEGAL, AND PLAIN WRONG.
>> I DO NOT SEE ANY LEGAL
OPINION THAT I CAN TAKE
SERIOUSLY THAT COUNTERS THIS.
>> THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL,
THEY ARE PAID TO LOOK AT THESE
KIND OF -- IT'S 30 PAGES LONG.
PEOPLE MAY DISAGREE WITH IT.
I THINK IT HAPPENS TO BE
CORRECT.
THIS ISN'T WHETHER IT WAS WISE
TO APPOINT MR. WHITAKER, WAS IT
WASN'T LAWFUL BOOKS MAKE UNDER A
SPECIFIC STATUTE PASSED BY
CONGRESS TO PERMITS THE
PRESIDENT WHAT HE DID.
>> Laura: JUDGE NAPOLITANO WAS
SAYING ABOUT THIS VERY ISSUE AND
THE OLC'S RULING ON THE WHITAKER
APPOINTMENTS.
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING D
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING S
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING P
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING O
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING N
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING E
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING D
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING H
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTING E
LAWYERS WORKING FOR MATTHEW
WHITAKER GOING BACK TO 1886 TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS
LAWFULLY APPOINTED.
I DON'T CARE WHAT HAPPENED IN
1866 BECAUSE THE CONGRESS
CHANGED THE LAW IN THE 1960s
AND SAID WHOEVER RUNS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OUGHT TO BE
NOMINATED BY THE PRESIDENT AND
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE BECAUSE
WE PUT TOO MUCH POWER IN THEIR
HANDS.
THAT KIND OF POWER CAN'T GO TO A
POLITICAL HACK.
>> Laura: OKAY, WELL,
POLITICAL HACK...
HE WAS A FEDERAL U.S. ATTORNEY
IN IOWA.
YOUR THOUGHTS AND WHAT
JUDGE NAPOLITANO SAID THERE!
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR MY
FRIEND JUDGE NAPOLITANO
SUGGEST -- WELL, I WAS
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT HE
DOESN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL
WORKS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT THEY DO IS
THINGS LIKE GO BACK TO THE
PRESIDENT'S THAT GO BACK TO THE
FOUNDING OF THE COUNTRY INTO THE
CONSTITUTION.
PARTICULARLY, LAURA, WHEN IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL CLAIM BEING MADE.
I UNDERSTAND JUDGE NAPOLITANO'S
POINT THAT THE STATUTE IS FROM
1998, BUT THE STATUTE IS NOT
WHAT PEOPLE ARE COMPLAINING
ABOUT.
IT'S WHETHER THIS APPLICATION OF
THE STATUTE IS CONSTITUTIONAL OR
NOT.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYERS GO ABOUT
MAKING THE ANALYSIS IS TO GO
BACK TO THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES AND SEE WHERE THE
SITUATION HAS COME UP AGAIN AND
HOW IT'S BEEN HANDLED.
>> Laura: JUDGE, DO YOU THINK
THAT MUELLER IS GOING TO WRAP
THIS THING UP?
>> I THINK SO.
THE INDICATION IS THAT WE ARE
MOVING ALONG BUT THERE MAY BE A
COUPLE OF MORE INDICTMENTS ON
THE WAY.
I THINK WE ARE READY FOR THERE
TO BE A RAP.
>> Laura: LIKE JEROME CORSI
AND ROGER STONE?